dernier point de couture sur le costume
arc en ciel depuis plus de quatre mois
ces petites mains prépare les 200
nouvelles tenues du brûlé les bandes et
à la proche de la première parade du
carnaval
les adhérents s'activent tard dans la
nuit
c'est un peu difficile mais on se sent
quand même ça va on a des ateliers
allons mal mardi
on a commencé le 15 septembre on avait
le mardi une fois sur deux depardon et
tous les samedis pour l'organisation
les participants se regroupent en
ateliers en fonction de leurs
compétences
nous sommes en train de réaliser des
boucles d'oreilles qu'on mettra samedi
pour le concours avec notre famille
coste une laque en ciel et les plus
jeunes ne sont pas en reste alors que
certains sur l'ambiance musicale
d'autres comme lenny s'attelle à la
confection des bracelets
tu vois un peu de colle encore mais
parfois les costumes les wasp les
lucquois tout j'aime tout le groupe peut
aussi compter sur sa doyenne à 81 ans
paul répond toujours présente
c'est quelque chose que j'aime j'ai
toujours aimé la couture la broderie le
crochet alors c'est une distinction pour
faire des économies
tout est fait à la main et l'association
récupère de nombreux objets malgré tout
l'élaboration des costumes représente un
budget conséquent qui avoisine les 7000
euros cette année on va dire de combien
ce qui bien souvent bien il joue le jus
nous elle un petit peu en l'achat de
fournitures au point de rappeler
et c'est un point nous opposer petites
choses il est vrai que le gru et
d'héritage des dépenses importantes que
les cotisations des adhérents ne
suffisent pas à prendre en charge
l'association est soutenue par sa
commune et son sponsor mais
régulièrement elle doit réaliser des
prestations pour gonfler son budget pour
eux
le carnaval c'est la sphère de toute une
année